[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy
veterans day america what a glorious day
in a glorious country or as the
democratic party describes it hell's
racist toilet
but maybe after seeing their own grim
handwriting on the wall probably in a
unisex bathroom they're trying to change
their own warped view of america have
you noticed a new word used by
frustrated democrats
it's normal yes as inflation illegal
immigration and crime spiral out of
control moderate dems are trying to
distance themselves from the idiotic
rabble promoting critical race theory
and 250 genders by saying hey we're
normal and i can't blame them they're
losing elections the way cat loses hair
extensions when she gets the spins
as the bite administration destroys
everything it gets its grubby hands on
remember how everything king midas
touched turned to gold well everything
joe touches turns to their parents
and says mommy why is this weird man's
nose in my hair
according to axios the news site not my
greek personal trainer
you can crack walnuts on its glutes
and i have
the word normal is the code word used to
separate some dems from their bonkers
colleagues they want americans to know
that the activist class within their
party doesn't speak for them
especially when they speak like this
with us in government
we campaign with the plan
uppercase t uppercase p v plan
and then the environment is such that
we're expected to defend the plan
wow
that was her doing a french accent while
in france
[Laughter]
and it was harder to watch than the
views swimsuit special
no wonder the white house keeps hiding
her like a bust of winston churchill
she's the vice president that has the
administration saying let's talk about
hunter biden's laptop
so they sent her to paris hoping she
might learn something like why deodorant
is so
important but at least jimmy kimmel
knows why people don't like her
americans really aren't happy with his
vice president kamala harris i think i
know why kamala's ratings are low
besides sexism and racism which are the
obvious ones ah the obvious ones well he
is the expert
on sexism and racism who who can forget
his pro-women work on the manchester
[Music]
oh that's progressive
and of course there are his efforts on
behalf of blacks
hello everybody out there tv town this
is carl malone of the utah jazz here to
tell you about call malone home state
louisiana
yeah i think he's the last guy to call
anyone racist or sexist but that's his
penance for his own indiscretions
smearing you he thinks will take the
heat off him he's like a
corporation going woke to hide their own
corruption and he smears a ton of people
including his own party remember harris
dropped out of the primaries because she
polled at 3 percent so i guess according
to kimmel that means 97 percent
of the democrats must be bigots
but maybe the dems don't know what
normal is anymore after denigrating it
for decades remember two parent
households were once normal now anything
qualifies as parenting love for country
was once normal but now we replaced a
pledge to our flag with a pledge to blm
respecting the police was once normal
now they're jealous of rodney
dangerfield
keeping violent criminals behind bars
was once normal now the norm is to set
them free like an injured bird you nurse
back to health and look i hate normal
believe me this is what i did this
morning before i came to work
[Music]
i hate normal
but the democrats have moved the goal
posts of normal into the parking lot
across the street
even virginia democrat abigail
spanberger complains that americans
elected biden to be normal and stop the
chaos
you know the chaos in the form of low
taxes control of our borders record low
unemployment energy independence
revolutionary vaccines that's some crazy
chaotic
wow trump was so abnormal or what we
used to call successful but that stuff
drove the elites crazy and it was all it
took to galvanize them to get rid of him
with completely fabricated scandals and
a secret election cabal
so here's the new normal courtesy of a
crooked media
the best way to get something done if
you if it holds near and dear to you
that you
like to be able to
i think i'm supposed to introduce
somebody but i'm not sure who am i
supposed to introduce
[Laughter]
i get you guys confused you know yeah
now unless you're a child talking in
your sleep that is not normal
but maybe it comes down to joe's
definition of normal as long as his life
retains its own normalcy who gives a
crap about yours i mean he just
discovered under his leadership that gas
has gone up and not just the stuff
coming out of his butt
do you ever think you're paying this
much for a gallon of gas
in some parts of california they're
paying 4.50 cents a gallon
thanks for noticing joe
nothing gets by you except the
occasional bm
but he's good with it because everything
is normal in his cloistered world he
still has his nap at 2pm which is
usually when he's being briefed about
the latest national security threats he
swims nude at 4 pm which is odd since
the public pool requires proper swimming
attire
henry removes his teeth at 7 pm
sometimes earlier if it's custard night
and in between he fits in destroying
afghanistan then they lock him inside
his room with a coloring book and a box
of crayons
joe says orange and red are his favorite
flavors
tibet has more autonomy the person in
charge really has more people
controlling him than britney spears
and yet i don't think i've seen so many
things go wrong in one administration at
one time
this white house is the political
equivalent of an al baldwin movie set
he hates the press and innocent people
suffer
remember those people who lied to us
about that joe was so moderate and so
calm true he is so different from trump
the same way my bikini pictures are so
different from margot robbie's
trump was in your face but he was also
in your reality
joe is rarely to be found even when he's
standing in front of you it's like
talking to a hologram and so it's
dawning on the dems this is not better
than a president who could call on
reporters all by himself you replace the
mean tweeter with inflation crime
afghanistan the migrant crisis a loss of
order in favor of divisive chaos that
splits a nation in two
i wonder what joe has to say
look look look i'm sick and tired of
talking about what's
normal and what isn't normal all right
look i understand gas prices are not
normal but you know what else
isn't normal opec
all right
you know what that stands for oil
peck
you know the thing all right and uh you
know what else isn't normal
kovid
1972 is when i first got into this
business i
i've been on this dance floor a long
time so i know normal you want to know
something that's not normal
i got a crappy painting i can sell you
for half a million dollars
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests
she knows so much about security we
asked her to work the door formula
deputy national security adviser and
author of the new book revolution
kt mcfarland
[Music]
[Applause]
people look up as tour gates to decide
when to be out of town writer comedian
joe devito
he's written for top late night shows
that are routinely beaten by this one
westernrazer.com owner david angelo
[Music]
and finally she's co-hosted cops and
been chased by them fox news contributor
cat tim
first i'm concerned uh david angelo you
have a thriving razor business
uh how is the supply chain fiasco
affecting your uh startup
well thanks for asking greg i appreciate
the interest in westernrazer.com
you know the supply chain has been tough
but you know we're made in america so
it's a little easier oh really the only
shortage we have we every razor is made
with love
and those mines have been closed for
months
so we've had some difficulty but we're
getting it together and they're in stock
so yeah there you go how can you uh uh
what do you make of this return to
normalcy david
who who's normal here i don't when
democrats say normal
yeah
democrats rebranding is normal when i
when i think normal you know nancy
pelosi and adam schiff don't pop into my
head
yeah this reminds me of like it's just
one of those bad rebrandings like when
philip morris was like we're altria now
we're like a pharmaceutical basically
you know yes everything's cool yeah
we're no longer tobacco tobacco sticks
or this mysterious whatever that still
makes cigarettes
anyway kt uh it's kind of interesting
that trump's abnormality
in government was that he got done and
that worked
and that's what was so abnormal and now
the return of normalcy is just
consistent nothing works anymore nothing
works
no i work for donald trump as his deputy
national security adviser in a lot of
ways he was like an idiot savant he
didn't do a lot of studying of the stuff
but instinctively he knew okay energy
independence secure the border america
first build up national security cut
taxes and it all worked and it was just
going great as he says yeah and tell
covington yeah what is the um what does
the revolution refer to in your book uh
that i think the country the united
states goes through these revolutionary
periods every 40 years and we're in the
middle of one now and trump was a
revolution against the republican party
what you're seeing now in the democrats
is their civil war they're having a
revolution where the looney left is
trying to take you in the direction but
america goes through these periods and
then we come out the other end and we
reinvent ourselves and i think that's
what we're doing right now outfitting
having biden as president yeah we're
coming out the other end
you know
i get another pink joke applause
you guys tried to cure me in my poop
jokes
joe you tried to stop my boob jokes and
you know what you failed because america
wants the poop jokes they applauded the
poop shapes
all right
joe joe joe it's amazing how amazed joe
biden was about the price of gas it kind
of makes me think that he's not that
engaged with the people that are
suffering well i think he's more used to
stage coaches and whips those more like
from his time his era
i think we're really starting to look at
kamala now and and say this is what's
supposed to be coming next yes because
she just set a new record low approval
rating for a vice president below dick
cheney who shot his friend in the face
okay
which usually knocks you down a little
bit yes and it's so funny to watch that
clip of her in france she there's
running out of places to send her that
are not the southern border right
they send her there she has the worst
french accent since the coneheads yes
i'm surprised she didn't laugh in french
and just go oh
instead of her
fake laugh
you know why don't they tell her that
they're going somewhere and take her to
the border right
like
because she was probably excited to go
to france well i'm picturing with one of
those old-timey suitcases that has the
stickers on it that say kathmandu paris
yes tibet you know instead of just
saying just go to that part of texas
where texas ends in california and go go
take a look there yes so cat uh
you know you look at joe and i've seen
cremated remains that are more
cognitively aware
oh how how are they gonna like what what
is gonna happen next i know that's an
open-ended question i think probably
more of this yeah is gonna keep
happening and happening and happening
um but also again it's kamala's even
less popular than joe biden is even
though like to her credit she can form a
sentence right like barely but
that's great right yeah um
but she also hasn't done anything which
is why it's so remarkable that her
approval rating is so low yeah like she
hasn't even tried anything yet or done
anything yet and it's already so low and
every time she does something it gets
even worse it probably was so low
because of that space video yes i think
you know they had a higher they had a
higher higher child actors to make her
look realistic
yeah which is weird but she's a perfect
life insurance policy for biden and
that's her function oh that's a
brilliant point you got to keep him
alive
oh well that's a great plan the guy's
150 years old
i don't think they thought this is true
like the way he acts even for his age i
saw my grandfather this weekend right
and you know he's almost 90 and if he
had started acting like that i'd be like
papa do we need to go to the hospital
like it's not as there's it's not just
the age i mean i won't live to be 80. so
i can't judge you paul and papa my papa
yeah hi papa
angelo that you always say that's the
solution to all problems just call
people papa
yeah when the kids call a parent papa
they're well behaved you ever know yes
yes that's true you never have a kid
like hey i'm not doing my homework i
don't care what you say papa
doesn't happen
we learned something new hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else